qué significaría una moneda común a
quienes va a beneficiar y a quienes
podría perjudicar
Buenas noches Valentina en principio es
simplemente un estudio que se está
haciendo en el marco de una cumbre de la
Celaya A quién va a beneficiar bueno en
función del ministro de economía de la
Argentina Esto está llamado a ser un
incentivo para intercambio comercial al
estilo un Swap con china que tiene
Argentina ya en vigencia no lo sabemos
esto reemplazaría al peso y el Real de
ninguna manera esto requiere de
mecanismo de coordinación extremos como
para que pueda reemplazar el día mañana
una de las monedas según lo que puede
verse de este proyecto en estudio que se
trata más de un proyecto que una
realidad creo yo y recordemos que esto
ya había pasado en 2019 entre macri
bolsonaro fallido esto había pasado hace
30 años atrás con Carlos menem el sueño
de una moneda común latinoamericana Esto
no es Europa está lleno de la simetría Y
si ustedes me ponen una economía que es
mucho más diferente con cualquier otra
en todo latinoamérica esa es Argentina
es un país muy difícil con el cual
coordinar este tipo de proyectos
bueno Y más allá de estos beneficios O
perjuicios es viable que en algún
momento se adopte por ejemplo lo que
usted estaba mencionando si lo hablamos
en materia de las diferencias entre las
economías en materia de inflación de
déficit fiscal
bueno pueden convivir de ninguna manera
reemplazarse las monedas porque una
moneda para ser como tal llamada moneda
debería cumplir las funciones de unidad
de cuenta que podría reemplazarla
tranquilamente Debería ser un medio pago
solamente para fines comerciales con lo
cual no se adaptaría para toda la
economía y finalmente como reserva de
valor si usted me dan una moneda con
reserva de valor donde está Argentina
detrás yo no la aceptaría y aquí los
ciudadanos así como en otros países de
latinoamérica se han adoptado al Dólar
como moneda de reserva bueno y algo
clave para que se pudiese implementar en
algún momento también sería superar la
polarización no solo entre los países de
izquierda y derecha sino también entre
la misma izquierda Porque por ejemplo
sabemos que chile no es partidario de
esta medida Cómo se lograría una posible
unidad al respecto
Bueno quién le va a dar respaldo dígame
si es Brasil me quedo más tranquilo
Brasil es una economía con 331 mil
millones de dólares de reserva Argentina
A duras penas y le sacamos todas las
deudas que tiene la reserva del Banco
Central son apenas de cinco mil
cuatrocientos millones de dólares son
reservas netas muy escasas Por lo cual
no tendría ni siquiera una participación
en esa moneda relevante se ha llamado
también a que otros países participen de
esta iniciativa lo cual le daría mucho
peso no es que uno se opone Pero uno ve
una economía con un 95% de inflación en
el 2022 proyectándose 98% inflación sin
crédito en los mercados internacionales
tienen casi reservas en el banco central
y la verdad que cuesta mucho imaginarse
el día de mañana de integración con una
moneda común con Brasil Pero reitero
supongo que esto convivirá el día de
mañana y para fines muy específicos como
fines comerciales y para eso hay
celebrar este tipo de acuerdo que
reducen la dependencia del dólar pero
que de ninguna manera lo reemplaza